افكار البشر هي ملكيه خاصه لكل شخص وحلم
الوصول اليها وقراءتها هي ماده بحث مثيره
لدى العلماء وكما يبدو ان ثوره الذكاء
الاصطناعي قربت الحلم بالفعل علماء بجامعه
في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه طوروا
تقنيه يمكنها قراءه ما يدور في عقول الناس
بحسب مشاهدينا صحيفه نيويورك تايم سمكنا
الباحثون في هذه الدراسه من تحويل الافكار
التي تدل تدور داخل عقل شخص ما الى كلام
فعلي وحينما تم استخدام تلك التقنيه في
وصف ما يدور في افلام صامته تمكنت من
تقديم وصف دقيق نسبيا لما يحدث على الشاشه
هذه
التقنيه الجديده تفضل اعاده يمكن ان تساهم
في مساعده بعض اصحاب الحالات المرضيه غير
القادرين على الكلام في التعبير عن انفسهم
لكن ماذا عن الجانب الاخلاقي هل سيرغب
البشر في فك شفره عقولهم ومشاركه
مع الاخرين دائما خلينا نقول بانه
ما خفي كان اعظم كما يقال بس ان تكونين
على العالم
اذا انا بعرف شو جوزي جوزي عن جد بفكر او
هو بيعرف انا بفكر بلاش تخيل مع مديري في
العمل مع زملائي في انا مش لانه انا عندي
افكار ما راح تخلينا نروح البيت والله
صدقني مصايب
ذكرني ب
فيلم زعقته ضربته صاعقه على راسه وصار
يسمع شو افكار الستات باخر الفيلم كان راح
ينتحريده اخر طيب خلينا نروح يعني على بر
الامان الى لميس اللي راح تفصل لنا هذه
الدراسه وطمنينا احنا علينا شيء يا لميس
ولا براءه
الباحثون الى نصوص المشاركين وهو منصورون
الى جهاز يقيس مستويات تدفق ضغط الدم الى
مناطق بالمخ واستخدموا تقنيه يمكنها عبر
الذكاء الاصطناعي ترجمه افكار الاشخاص من
خلال تحليل صور رنين المغناطيسي لتدفق
الدم الى مناطق مختلفه في المخ هذه
التقنيه استطاعت تحويل الصور التي انتجها
جهاز لقياس التدفق الدم نحو المخ الى نصوص
مكتوبه حيث استمع المشاركون في الدراسه
الى تسجيلات جديده وتمت مراقبه تدفق الدم
الى المخ وتحويل تلك الصور الى نصوص
مكتوبه وبالفعل كان
المعنى الصياغه مختلفه للمقطع الصوتي
الاصلي كما طلب من المشاركين في الدراسه
تخيل قصه في عقولهم خلال اتصالهم بجهاز
قياس مستوى تدفق الدم الى المخ قبل ان
يحقدك القصه بصوتهم كمرجع يمكن العوده
اليه وبالفعل ايضا تمكن الباحثون من تحويل
تلك الصور الى النصوص مشابهه للقصص التي
تخيلها المشاركون
[تصفيق]
مشاهدينا سنذهب الان الى الرياض حيث
المؤثر والمهتم في التقنيه فيصل السيف
اهلا بك
سلمي لي عليه كثير السلام الله
يخليك يعني
انا يعني عندي رايي في هذا الموضوع موضوع
قراءه الافكار انا برايي انه هذا الشيء
خارق للخصوصيه بشكل خارق حتى اكثر من
الفيش والراك اكثر من بصمه الايد وبصمه
الوجه وكل هذا الكلام حتى رح يعرف يدخل
جوا دماغي ويعرف انا ايش عم بفكر يعني انت
اصلا كيف ممكن نوصل تقنيا لانه نقرا افكار
الاخرين بشكل دقيق خلينا نبلش بهاي
الجزئيه جدا ممتاز صبحكم الله بالخير من
جديد الحين فكره بالخصوصيه نعم 100% ولكن
هذا الامر لم يقف ام لم يتسبب في ايقاف اي
من الابحاث الماضيه فبالتالي
عندما يبدو فيصل عماله بيخرق خصوصيتنا
بشكل خارق برضه صحيح صحيح 100% بس الحين
خليني اوضح الفكره اللي قاعده تصير ايضا
مع بحث ثاني صار في جامع سويسريه لما
جابوا
تجارب فار مختبره ابيض وعرضوا عليه فيلم
اكسل دو اوصلوا من داخل العقل الى الخارج
عشان تقيس الترددات تجربه مشابهه في قدروا
يشوفوا بالضبط ايش التخطيط اللي قاعد
تشوفه يشوفه من عيونه من خلال مشاهده فيلم
الابيض والاسود على اساس مره بسيط
فبالتالي يقدروا مع الذكاء الاصطناعي
يحولوا هذه الاشارات اللي تجي من عقله الى
مشاهد مشابهه فبالتالي طلعوا بالمعادله
انه وش يشوف كيف يشوفه عقله كيف يفسره
فبعدها لما يبدا يشوفوا الترددات اللي
موجوده في العقل قد تنتج منها مشاهد هي
اللي قاعده بخيط الفارطه نفس التجربه
بالضبط اللي قاعده تصير في تكساس الموضوع
من عام 1960 الابحاث قاعده تشتغل في هذا
الامور الفكره طبيعيه جدا ممتازه بل حسنه
بشكل جدا عظيم اين استخدمت بطريقه صحيحه
فتخيلوا انه اجهزه زي هذه الاشارات اللي
موجوده في العقل هنا هذه تقدر تستشعرها
فبالتالي تساندني هذه الاجهزه اني اهدي
نفسي او اني اركز اكثر او اني اساعد نفسي
فيه ارشاد عقلي قوه عقلي الى مكان محدد
الموضوع اشوفه حسن اكثر من الموضوع مو
كويس يعني يعني خليني خليني اسالك اكثريه
الذكاء الاصطناعي اليوم فيصل بانه ممكن
يحدد بناء على معطيات انت تقدمها انه
توقعات وسيناريوهات لما تحتاجه او ما تفكر
فيه لكن احيانا يقول لك الرجل او حتى
المراه مثلا
متغيره الافكار وفق المكان والزمان
والحاله النفسيه هذه شلون راح يقراها
الذكر الذكاء الاصطناعي
احد المعضلات الكبيره اللي مستحيل الذكاء
الاصطناعي في وقتنا الحالي بالعلم اللي
موجود انها يوصلها لانه بالفعل كان البشري
ما يميزه عن الذكاء الاصطناعي انه في
عوامل خارجيه وداخليه تؤثر فيه وفي
قراراته وفي كل شيء قاعد يدور في عقله فمن
الهرمونات تقيله المزاج الى المود الى
كميه الكافيين في جسمك هل المتغيرات
الكثيره نوم مرتاح تعبان شاده على الاعصاب
شديد كلها تؤثر في قراراته على عكس الذكاء
الاصطناعي واحاديه لا تشمل المشاعر ولا
فيها اي مبدا من التاثيرات الخارجيه الا
البيانات
بسبب عظمه سبحان رب العالمين الخالق في
خلق الانسان الى الحين يعتبر معضله
فقاعدين نكتشف اشياء نقرا افكار ونشوف
اشياء بسيطه ولكن لابد تدريب الاله لك
تمكين قراءه الافكار بل الافكار تختلف
بطريقه قرائها عند كل واحد فيكم وانا لو
جو دربوا الاله على قراءه افكار لن ينطبق
الموضوع على اي واحد ثاني غير اللي دربه
الاله عليه ما عين الورق فبتتطور بتصير
بشكل سطحي اما انه يصير نعرف مئه في الميه
اللي قاعد يصير نوعا ما مستبعده حاليا كان
انه الى الحين نطور الاله ولكن خلق الله
سبحانه رب العالمين الى الحين
ننجح وهو اللي قاعد بانه مشوار قراءه
الافكار بدا بخطوه واحده لم ينتهي وما
وصلناش لمرحله نقدر نقرا افكار الاخرين
بشكل دقيق بس يعني انت ذكرت بانه هو ممكن
يكون شيء مفيد مثلا في حال في ناس راقدين
انه هاي طريقه ممتازه للتواصل مع الاخرين
ولكن ما في خوف بانه يتحول لنوع من انواع
الاخ الاكبر اللي تحدث عنها
روايته 1984 بانه احنا راح نكون مراقبين
بشكل تام في كل الاوقات ليس فقط بوين
بنكون موجودين عن طريق وجهنا وبصمه وجوهنا
وبصمه ايدينا ولكن حتى عن طريق افكارنا
جميل جدا الحين هذا التطور او هذا التصور
مستقبلي بيننا وبينه على الاقل اربعين الى
خمسين سنه علميه فهنا نعرف انه هذه الامور
بانها تصير شيء ماس ويستخدم بشكل عام
بيننا وبين وقت طويل ففي المصطلح المبسطه
اللي اقدر استخدمه المعادله اللي هي
رايحين حياتهم طيبه امورنا طيبه لسه
انهم يقدروا يعبروا عن مشاعرهم بعضهم في
حالات الشلل اللي موجوده قد لا يوجد اي
نوع من انواع الحركه ولا حتى الرموش ولكن
قد يكون هناك كثير من الامور تدور في بعله
وبالتالي يحتاج للتواصل فهنا تخيلوا كميه
العلم اللي حنطلع فيها وكميه التمكين اللي
حتصير من هذه الامور اذكركم بولد دكتوره
مريم السيف هنا موجود عندنا وهي اللي طلعت
بيه مبادره تمكين الولد صار له حادث فقد
الحركه بشكل جدا كبير في جسمه ما عنده
اسلوب النطق ولكن الحين ما شاء الله عليك
اما دراسه الجامعيه وايضا الف كتاب وتمم
اكثر من امر وكله بتسخير التقنيه علشان من
الرموشه وعيونه قاعد يسوي الامور ويتواصل
مع الناس ويستخدم بالتصويب الاله وياخذ
ويعطي فكانت حياته متوقفه الى ان بفضل رب
العالمين مكنتها التقنيه ورجع
طيب فيصل سيف يعني شكرا جزيلا المؤثر
والمهتم في التقنيه يعطيك الف عافيه على
كل هذه المعلومات ان شاء الله ما حد يقدر
افكارنا يا فيصل النساء ما حد يعرف
افكارهم
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات